hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast explore precision medicine QC
I interpret we lucid a precision in
breast cancer targeted therapy I am Judy
O'Rourke live lab groups can all be your
moderator for today's event today's
webcast is presented by labyrinth comm
the leading social media site for
science professionals and sponsored by
cryogen bioinformatics private and
bioinformatics is powered by CLC bio
ingenuity and bio base
the company offers bioinformatics where
tools for next-generation sequencing NGS
data analysis and interpretation it's
solutions are designed to be universal
so customers can mix and match the
technology best suited to their needs
for more information please visit WWE
Champion for medics calm before we start
there are a few instructions this
webinar has been approved for continuing
educational credits please click on the
CD button at the bottom left corner and
follow the process to receive your
credits we want to hear from you during
this interactive broadcast so please ask
questions or leave us a comment
answers are welcome to and you can do
this by hitting the green Q&A button to
the lower left of the presentation
window and typing in your comments and
questions we'll try to get to as many as
we can and we'll follow up if we don't
have time today want a better look you
can enlarge the slide window by clicking
on the screen icon in the lower right
hand corner of the slide window if you
can't hear or see this presentation
properly let us know by clicking on the
support button on the top right or use
the Q&A button we'll make sure we try to
resolve any issue now let's get right to
today's presenter we are proud to
welcome Julie Duchenne's MBA PhD dr.
Duchenne's is the manager for advanced
genomics at Cliveden bioinformatics she
is a strong customer advocate working
closely with customers and partners
identifying insights in their NGS and
expression analysis data and
facilitating the implementation of their
clinical decision support software dr.
Duchenne's come
her PhD in biochemistry and molecular
biology in 2008 at the Institute for
Research in immunology and cancer in
Montreal
she studied breast cancer by looking at
the transcriptional regulation of
estrogen receptors to the DNA through
long-range regulation by estrogen
she has been an author on numerous
peer-reviewed articles and spoken on a
variety of high-level panel symposiums
and conference sessions Dr Chen's
recently obtained an executive mba on
market strategy for a next-generation
sequencing clinical reporting software
from these vs burg university tot
germany while supporting the market
entry of client clinical insight
interpret vill hon where are apne PhD
will answer attendees questions during
the Q&A session following the
presentation dr. Whitney is a senior
scientist working in advanced genomic
support at kya gen bioinformatics
specifically he has a cancer genomic
scientists invested in leveraging the
explosion of genomics data to transform
cancer treatment and patient outcomes he
has more than a decade of experience in
cancer genomics and precision oncology
both connected and Industry settings dr.
Whitney obtained his PhD in neuroscience
and molecular biology from the
University of Vermont in 2007 event
joined Harvard Medical School and the
Broad Institute of MIT to do
postdoctoral research in majula blastoma
genomics this work was instrumental in
defining the current World Health
Organization accepted molecular
subgroups of majula blastoma following
his postdoctoral work Johan transition
to biopharma and worked at leading
diagnostics companies including thermo
Fisher and then of one focusing on
clinical interpretation and annotation
of biomarkers in solid and hematological
tumors clinical reporting and developing
pharmacogenomics biomarker knowledge
bases their complete bios are found on
the lab routes website I will now turn
it over to dr. Duchenne's for her
presentation
Thank You Julie so for today's
presentation dr. rusty and I or variant
scientists we work together in building
this presentation which we hope will
illustrate how clinical decision support
software such as the current platform
here allow laboratory to address
challenge in genomics so without further
intro let's get started so during the
presentation today we will essentially
you know start with or qci platform or
QC I interpret and then we will go into
the breast cancer facts so as you know
breast cancer is a complex at the
Virginia's disease which each time each
subtype characterized by distinct
clinical feature in molecular a duration
the advance in NGS are presented unique
treatment unfortunately beyond
certification of patient by Ormond
receptor and if the Merle growth factor
receptor status so that presentation
today will demonstrate how to like you
see I can help laboratory in oncology so
for to illustrate that we have
essentially selected five different case
to case coming from the TCGA atlas on
the somatic side of the breast cancer to
case coming from there originally signs
of breast cancer in one last case which
represents essentially triple negative
example and then after I'm going through
the different cases and how you can
leverage qci with the interpretation of
those cases I would conclude with a
summary and the learning objective will
be to for you to see the utility of QC I
enter press in identifying molecular
restoration see how treatments and
clinical trial decision support can be
you it can be done by using tools such
as QC I and then see how we can
demonstrate the richness of the Kaiser
knowledge base using this tool before we
get started I have to put some antennas
use
meant about UCI sook UCI is an
evidence-based decision support software
intended as an aid in the interpretation
of variant observe in genomics narration
it is not intended as a primary
diagnosis tool by physician or to be
used as a substitute for professional
healthcare when we think about NGS and
when we think about the challenge in the
clinical genomic testing there's a lot
of different challenge if we start with
the first one we can see that you know
the first challenge is often the
scalability and accuracy of the
interpretation and reporting in essence
you have a lot of different data you
have a lot of data to analyze at any
given time so what this is one of the
challenge that can be addressed and will
be addressed with the tools such as qci
the next challenge that Clinical
Laboratory has is also maintaining the
risk with your test menu expansion so
often what may happen is that you will a
laboratory would start testing one case
one type of case and then one an
additional disease area and another one
and another one therefore not only you
need a structure that would be capable
allow you to get all these different
tests menu but also making sure that
this is done and and in a way where you
can really have your test menu that
expands and provides rich information
similarly across all of them another
challenge is the continuous improvement
that you may have in running your lab
into making sure that you are getting
good operational efficiency that your
turnaround time is quick as quick as
possible and then you're keeping your
production class and then finally what
is also important with genomic testing
is also making sure that you're
continuously learning and about the new
science about the new drug about the new
clinical trial and so forth so you are
able to bring essentially a lot of
different information all the time
so these are challenge that
Karin is trying to address with this
solution so the end result of that is
what we call the actionable report so
which is what essentially clinical
laboratory often has to do which is
starting with running the task make the
interpretation and then serve three
basic questions you know when you do
that interpretation you you want to know
as a variant scientist or as a
laboratory director is the observed
variant real for example is it
clinically relevant that doesn't matter
to have that variant essentially and
more importantly is this actionable so
are you talking about a variant that
doesn't carry any actionability
therefore may be less important into the
clinic so these are the type of question
that in today's presentation I will use
the five different case study in breast
cancer to illustrate the benefit and the
read of the knowledge of qci and how it
can help answering those questions for
laboratory but before diving into into
the case study itself it is important to
realize that clinical decision support
tool are only as good and accurate as
they are build on a strong foundation so
the collagen knowledge base is a
solution that has been done in making
for almost 17 years now where we
essentially have to dynamic from one
side we have the content acquisition
dynamic which is essentially been for
more than 17 years the hydrogen
bioinformatics area throughout the
different acquisition has been training
a lot of variety of information from
basic research clinical information
licking just to treatment and so forth
now that content is a lot of information
to take in therefore what you what you
also need is making sure that you
support all the content with a structure
anthology that allow you to essentially
making sure if you can connect the
different dots so making sure that you
can connect things like patients in
aside with disease mechanism with sinan
or mechanism that
sort of thing to make sure that you have
the whole story and the whole picture
before your particular variant and this
is what is it the essence in the core of
the current knowledge base and the
current knowledge base is essentially a
leverage by the qci platform that we
will see during this presentation so we
are just off of the you know the October
month where October was the awareness
month for breast cancer we're not
getting into November and so forth but
it is important to realize address
cancer is you know an important and
still an important disease area it is
just in the United States touching about
one of nine women or 12% of the woman
would get wrist cancer at some point in
time in your life there is a lot of
different new cases among four breast
cancer
the survival rate is is good there is a
five-year survival rate of ninety ninety
percent or wherever breast cancer can
quickly metastasize and different other
part of the body therefore it is really
important to be able to have sufficient
tool to address that throughout the
whole continuum of different type of of
cancer
there's mainly two different type of
cancer and as you probably a lot of you
are from a year where you know a lot of
the way to classify is to classify them
with their biomarker so many breast
cancer for example will have Express or
two or a rbb two estrogen receptor
progesterone receptor and these
biomarker are use you know in targeted
therapy put a different patient however
there's also a component where about 15
to 20 percent of the patients will be
triple negative for on these biomarker
so what we saw we would do during this
presentation today is we'll essentially
use we use TCGA published cases these
are real patient cases that has been
published and we're using them to
illustrate how a solution
you see I interpret can be can allow you
to address all the challenge that you
may have in you know in the clinical
laboratory so the first two as I
mentioned will be about two different
cases of somatic cases where the driver
mutation in those cases are more around
pik3ca a p53 and so on then we will take
a look at an example with a bracket one
driver mutation as well as an example
with the bracket two driver mutation and
then finally we will take a look at a
particular case which was triple
negative with regards to the classic
biomarker where on the driver mutation
is most likely more around Matt - kinase
so um in that is you know that is
allowing that allowing us essentially to
to show you the breadth of the different
type of information you can get within
the system with today's presentation I
will be for simplicity I will be using a
slide presentation but throughout my
presentation what you will see is a lot
of different screen captures or the
clinical the qci tool is a cloud-based
solution that essentially will allow you
to reach you send or submit within a
NEPA compliance way obviously submit the
variant file information and then see
all the richness of the information
around the particular case and then and
then look and potentially report out on
the information based on the case so
today I will use slide to do this
exercise but this is a web cloud
application that can be really unboard
and spin off and and used by a customer
really quickly so let's sign into this
specific case so the first case is the
case of a 43 years old
asian woman when she she came based on
the information she was presenting it
was a stage to a breath invasive ductal
carcinoma
her status was or to negative PR and ER
positive she had Baraka 1 & 2 variant as
well whoever based on the case and based
on the information available the driver
restoration in that particular case was
most likely a pik3ca in the p53 and
that's what I will spend most of my time
just discussing about so now let's let's
essentially go and look into the data so
once you know what we did is we
essentially submitted the variant call
file the information for that particular
case into the system and what you see
when you launch the interface is some
sort of a dashboard and I know it might
be really really small from your side of
the computer but what you essentially
have is a dashboard that allows you to
see three different sections one is the
variants list which is essentially all
the different variants is in this case
so it's important to know that here for
the interest of this case study we are
presenting only their semester or cancer
important variant we have ma these were
all genome old exam samples so we did
not load all the different variants we
kept only what was relevant in the
context of oncology but what we see here
is essentially my dashboard that is
presenting to me five different variants
three of them are color coded as as red
which means pathogenic so these are
variant that are obviously caring Cepeda
genetic information so there is in
particular p3 CA which we will take a
look at a lot during during this
presentation in lenders as well p53 you
can see for each of those variants we
have different markers or different
flags that essentially allow the end
user to see actionability information
you can see things such as treatment
cynical trial and so forth so you you
are really able to have an idea quickly
about what might be relevant or
actionable in these particular cases and
I want to point out to you these bracket
1 & 2 variants they were in gray which
mean that they're caring in uncertain
significance and what does that mean is
they're not necessarily actionable based
on all the computed justification that
went through them there are most likely
not the one that is driving data genic
importance for that particular example
so if we dive a little bit more into the
information that you can get into this
vast board is you have information about
the specific variant that is eye lighted
so highlighted pik3ca within the context
of cancer so I can see things such as
what is the particular variant what is
the protein translation information so
this these are key information that the
variant scientists will need to use in
order to be able to to make your
decision there is things such as somatic
frequency population frequency and
infraction and so on that are also
information that might be useful when
you address and you look at the cases
but what is most importantly is to get
into the details for each of the
variants in some cases you may say
especially if you see those every single
day you may say I know this is the
driver variant and you move on and you
do your reporting but in some other
cases you may want to go and dive into
this specific information and that's
what I will do here with p3 CA
let's dive into what we called very in
detail the variant detail is essentially
a section that is divided in a lot of
different sub section that allow you to
see specific pinpoint information there
is obviously things such as a variant
detail the assessment information how
does how does how can you see I say this
particular variants example list out a
genic that sort of thing
there is things such as the treatment
information
reported clinical case counts and so
forth so if we first take a look at the
variant detail the variant detail allows
us to see things such as the chromosome
the position there is a few different
links you know that you can see so if
for example you're coming at a cross and
you want to know what a piece big three
see I do is it is really rather than
usually in breast cancer or an auto type
of cancer you can quickly go and look at
different types of information such as
the gene review databases allow you to
read about that specific gene the health
condition for the specific gene and so
forth so quickly the interface is
allowing you to navigate through all the
specific information that you may need
to decide about this particular variant
if we take a look now into diving into
the specific information where is the
variant this type of information is
represented in the section that we call
missense effect on the protein or the
effect on the protein so here what you
have is where essentially where is the
variant so the very end is where this
black line here so this variant here is
in the eggs all ten of pik3ca it is in
this particular section that we have
here in yellow which represent the
critical domain of the protein and
throughout the interface you can see
this little red bar it would allow you
to to know whether or not the variance
is in a spot and we can see if we take a
look at what is around this variant we
can see that essentially this particular
variant is indeed you know a spot so
based on the literature evidences there
is a lot of variant in that region that
are deemed to be pathogenic in the
literature there is also information
that you can see around gain-of-function
so if I click on the little I and this
is through throughout the interface I
will get information in this particular
case I have information about why
is this variance comparing a gain of
function so this variance is it's
comparing in a function based on the
literature information so I quickly can
see why does the software tells me it's
a gain or a loss of function for example
so it's really allowing me to see the
rich contextual information there now
you may say in some cases you may say
well I want to know more about what is
actually the literature is there
clinical case in the literature that is
talking about that specific is variant
and are they in my specific disease of
interest so when you look and open their
reported clinical case counts you will
have this some sort of diagram that
would represent for you the type of
literature evidences that kind of
curated and what I mean by that is
Kaiser really has employee that their
sole role is to curate literature and
making sure that they were grabbing
contextual information around the
specific variant ethnicity when it's
available and that sort of thing so all
of these different icon represents a
piece of information that we are
actually we have created manually
following a strict protocol and it might
not be that obvious in the broadcast but
you can see that there is different you
know the shape or a little bit different
so essentially the interface allow you
to see whether these literature evidence
are coming from the somatic information
coming from errors it sorry information
if it's Irizarry is it coming from
segregation type of cases and so forth
so you can really have grasped an idea
of the contacts and here quickly without
they've been diving into the information
I know that there is you know a huge
majority of the clinical case in the
literature today that are around some
aspects that specific variant now if I
want to know more and dive into the
specific information I can click the
open option and then it will open for me
Oh
specific cases or here we can see
highlighted here this is a publication
that was published earlier in September
so since we are releasing content
information on a weekly basis if our
creator a curated something last week
you will be able to see it this week
into the system so here is the case of a
literature that is talking about that
particular variants in primary breast
cancer and also in metastatic breast
cancer where other cases I've had that
same pik3ca and so it's not just you
know some math and you know another
surface cancer like a variant cancer
that sort of thing it's really these are
primary clinical case in the literature
that are around breast cancer and you
can variant scientists at this point if
it feels Azim that the particular
literature evidence is relevant then
they can quickly click on on this icon
here and add the information to the
report so this little square icon that I
just highlighted in yellow is
essentially a way to click in the
software to say I want to put this in my
report or I don't want to put this in my
report so it you can quickly add the
literature evidences into your report
which is what exactly I did for this
particular one that we can see here so
you can essentially add add this so how
do you review the information you can
already without noticing building your
report if you want to go and dive into
the particular article one thing to keep
in mind is everything in in blue here
everything I lighted in blue in the
software will allow it to go be directed
to the primary information so here it
will be PubMed for example which is
exactly what I did
so you can click on that blue link and
you will get into the primarily two
richer evidences and if your institution
has access and you can directly go and
then access the publication so if we now
we've seen
with that pik3ca we can learn about what
is pik3ca in the contacts we can access
information about whether or not that
particular variant has been seen in
other clinical case around breast cancer
which we have confirmed in in any
laboratory one of their goal is also to
provide treatment either treatment or
clinical trial and this is what we can
see here when you open the treatment
information you can essentially access
an interface that allow you to dive into
the treatment and clinical trial
information based on on whether the
treatment are the clinical trial it
corresponds to the exact variant which
there's none in this particular case we
don't see any treatment we don't see any
trial or whether you're looking at the
entire gene and you can ask a question
within your specific cancer which is
what I did here in breast cancer or you
can also go and see the information for
any type of cancer so if we dive into
that specific information and we look at
any type of treatment or trial within
breast cancer that's exactly what I have
here I can first notice that there's
still no treatment so there's no
approved treatment at this point in time
for armpit 38 itself but the bottom part
is the clinical trial so here we can see
a few different clinical trial and
unfortunately I cannot scroll because
you would have been able to see all of
them I had only four in my screen
capture but you essentially have
different trial that are currently
enrolling so at this point in time or at
least laughs update which we do every
week typically on Thursday then you have
a clinical trial that are currently
enrolling you can narrow it down which
we did here we kind of kept
within the United States for the purpose
of the case sorry but you can narrow
that down to the primary location where
I'm the physician ears the ordering
physician for example is and that sort
of thing
so if we dive into the treatment
information and then take a look and
again I do apologize because it's a
little bit small on the screen but you
can see for the first treatment and
trial actually it is it is a big 3 CA
where er BB 3 is negative so it's a case
of a treatment or ear victory CA
mutation is present erbb2 is negative
which corresponds to this particular
case and estrogen receptor is positive
whoever when we take a look at the
description in the study of the date
title i alighted and blue here that in
this particular criteria for enrollment
is this trial is open to postmenopausal
woman which was not the case of this
particular case therefore this drawn in
this particular case will would not be
applicable for for that particular TCGA
case however if we look into a tiny bit
lower you have you essentially have the
phase 3 if it's risky any bidder that
have clinical case that are and you know
clinical treatment that trial sorry that
are currently enrolling for which this
the particular the case could be you
know applicable so essentially I D or
villain did made them as reportable so
these are clinical case that can can go
within within the report of that
particular case and once you once the
variant scientist in the laboratory
director I was on reviewing all this
particular information then you can
essentially go and dive into you know
more detail and why the assessments for
example was on and then generated report
so here we can see the different
criteria or rule of that main district 3
CA
assessment possible for pathogenicity so
you have all the
different criteria if the laboratory do
not agree with it they can always change
the different criteria on the fly so
it's it's allowing you to essentially
turn on or off on the computer
justification this is something that
it's not applicable for a given case and
once you agree with the assessment and
you are ready to generate the report you
essentially go and then you click on the
last on tab which is reviewing report
and that allows the variant scientists
of the laboratory director to put their
overall interpretation on the case and
also allow them to put overall
interpretation on the different variants
that you have so Kaizen already provides
some sort of facts but the it allows you
to to enrich add contextual information
around the particular variant and even
save it for reuse next time and if we
think about the more the biology of the
reality of this case in this particular
case what the interface allow us to look
at is that bracket the bracket one and
two while you know people wincing over
at Canterbury want to type thing there
were not pathogenic in this particular
case pic sorry CA was an activating this
is an activating mutation in a spot
region it's eligible for clinical trial
a different few clinical trial in breast
cancer for pik3ca and what we have not
looked at there is also potential
clinical trials for the p53 mutation
that could be done so when you go
through the whole interface you can
essentially make the type of conclusion
and and finally generate generate a
report and the report engine can either
be an electronic information that is in
your you know within your laboratory or
like this which is essentially a PDF and
that would contain all the information
about the specific cases so now if we if
we take a look when we were doing this
case study one of the thing we were
wondering and one
question I was asking villainous what
about manual breast cancer so can we
take a look at an example of male breast
cancer and and see it's a difference is
it is it the same and that's what we
have done so as you for the next case as
you may know main breast cancer is
really really rare there's about 2,000
different patients new patients in the
United States that are newly diagnosed
every year in average who ever what we
will show here is that essentially the
it's theology of breast cancer trans and
gender so what we will take a look at
when we will look at the variance is
that pik3ca is is also it's the
different variants it is also a gene
that has carry and the driver
restoration in this case if we think
about the case itself it's a 68 years
old Hispanic gentleman that was
presented with the stage 2b luminal B
invested the carcinoma he was or two
negatives er tr+
the bracha were negative in this
particular cases the ethology was really
similar to female breast cancer in that
particular case so we did a similar
exercise where we essentially took a
look at the variant that were relevant
for for oncology in this particular case
and we there was not a lot of them that
were only relevant but there was one
that was striking which was the pik3ca
variant again it's a different variant
it is also a pathogenic variant as you
can see the profile of the literature
evidence compared to the other one in
this cases we see that it's a little bit
more half-and-half where you have a lot
of somatic clinical cases in the
literature but you also have a good
amount of the literature coming from
something a little bit more inherited or
individual die but not not necessarily a
somatic cases so these are type of
information jab you able to gather
really quickly
and when we go and we dive into the
treatment of a clinical trial it's a
similar story so we're also looking here
about all the specific clinical trial
around big 3ca
and in this case though if you think
about a male it's a male is essentially
some what could be considered as a as a
post into the menopausal situation so it
is possible that that's first royal that
we're looking at earlier could be
relevant for that particular case so
that might be something that the
laboratory director may want to
investigate further into him after the
criteria specific criteria of the of the
clinical trial and so forth so the
interface is really allowing the
laboratory director to have access to
this information and quickly decide
whether or not this is relevant but in
you know in in conclusion when we think
about this this male is that well why
they are really rare cases the disease
etiology and the type of gene that are
affected can be really similar like we
can see in this particular case and in
this one it is also a big touristy
activating mutation in a spot region and
potentially the same clinical trial
could be you know with pik3ca any litter
can could be of interest for the
laboratory director to put into the
report so the next thing we said well
well you know it's not if you have an
interface that allow us to take a look
at somatic cases but what about
inherited oncology what about interest
in breast cancer what can we do with an
interface such as PCI and that's what we
did for the next two cases so we
selected two cases of arras is everyone
one case coming from a bracket one
driver mutation and a different case
coming from a bracket two driver
mutation so this first one is the case
of
39 years electric an American woman
presented with stage 2b cancer as well
in the upper left quadrant
she was her2 negative PR and er positive
the broadcast adder was bracket 1000
says no bracket - variant in this
particular case she at the time of the
sequencing she was pre pre menopausal in
this case and some of you know a little
bit more more involved with particular
disease area and so forth you know
bracket one or often more typical not
always but more typical of ovarian that
will be in mummification individual and
that was kind of one of the question we
were having and whether when we look at
the contents or the information in the
knowledge base whether we this was
reflected as well so when we uploaded
this into the interface we first confirm
that this baraka one variant or dis
variances record wand was indeed
pathogenic based on ACMG classification
this variant when we take a look at the
assessment there's a lot of different
criteria such as you know new variant
variant that is not present in any
databases there's also information about
cab information or effect of the gene
and the gene product essentially that's
where of interests for this one if we
when we opened the bibliography
information we have found one
bibliography so there was really one
case in the intimate enricher at the
time we did this which is about a month
ago and at that time there was one
particular militia richer evidence that
was talking about it so we and that one
wasn't affected cases so we took a look
at when this publication was about and
this is this is a publication that
well that's invariant in the barakatu
gene and it was observed in breast
cancer but in Lebanese so inherited
bracket1 variant in the Nipponese
population in this particular
publication somewhere was published in
2015 which was really interesting for us
and confirming in a bit where we could
say okay there's really just this notion
of a different ethnicity that can carry
this this variant has a familial in
narrative cases so we we were able to
look at that information by accessing
this this publication in when we think
about treatment and trial there is some
things that can that can essentially be
done with regards to Rekha one variant
here so there is the standard therapy of
this way but there's also when we think
about therapies in the case of Rekha one
there's a leper herb for example that
it's currently approved by FDA EMEA and
NCCN for for variant cancer so what we
were interested in looking into you
where or not so this is an approved drug
in a different cancer and ovarian cancer
so not that far from breast cancer
essentially and the question was whether
or not there's actually clinical trial
as well for for breast cancer for
example and that's what we took a look
by looking up the clinical trial and
there is indeed and I apologize again
but there's indeed different clinical
trial with elaborate others that are
also afforded you know also open
currently for the signal generation of
barbed inhibitor so essentially in
breast cancer
so essentially you know the laboratory
and the mystical team could could have
two different avenues here they could
you could ask for the rotation and go
into trying to get at arrogation to have
a treatment of is approved for variant
cancer for that particular case or they
could you could also and
this particular patient in indifferent
clinical trial that are more relevant
for for breast cancer
um that's essentially the conclusion of
this particular case so which would be
units to look into decision generation
PARP inhibitor essentially as a clinical
trial so our next case was about a
residuary now Brett and racket - so in
the case of racket - so we have at 51
years old Caucasian female although was
presented with the stage 3 she was
pretty menopausal in our cases and we
essentially did similar exercise and I
would go a little bit faster here but
essentially we went into you know what
are the different variants at the time
base on the computed classification the
bracketry was a likely path so a little
bit less stronger there was some NKT in
there but the the bracketry was more
likely pathogenic in this particular
case and the assessment when we were
looking at the assessment were just you
know a little bit less evidences or rule
based on athe classification that was
less strong more moderate type of rule
therefore the computer classification
couldn't tell us that this was you know
ketogenic for sure it's likely
fettuccini so it's not as strong as the
the previous case we have seen obviously
if you take a look and raqqa - it's a
similar finger is indeed you know the
PARP inhibitor that you can also take a
look with with the bracket - variant as
well which is similar stories in the
previous case when you get into these
type of treatment because they are
relevant for for both the bracket 1 or 2
so it's again you know that same
endpoint very regards to the treatment
but you can really see how how the
computer classification can allow you to
navigate through to the different
variant and see whether they are para
genic likely pathogenic and all of that
is computed in a matter of a few minutes
when you submit the file to the
interface and honestly because for the
sake of completeness we wanted to
and I said but what about triple
negative what about those cases where
there's no known you know there's no
tariffs or or db2 estrogen receptor
progesterone receptors so they're really
negative for for that information
what type of very under is in those type
of cases so in this particular one it
was a triple negative breast cancer case
it was a case of 50 years old Caucasian
woman and as you know you know it's a
little more important handles and
critical because these the these
particular woman cannot even go to to
things like entry estrogen like
tamoxifen aromatase inhibitor and that
sort of thing
so that was one of the interests that we
have by looking into into that specific
case and when we took a look if we send
the interface we found variance in p53
but also a variance within the map to
Cantonese which based on on or very
scientists essentially experience
there's most likely the driver mutation
in a particular cases so it's about two
counties and augmentation there was also
a loss of function with p53 when you
take a look at the different treatment
there is different treatment you know
map suit counties there is for the exact
variant resistance but there's also
therapy for Matthew Kennedy's where
where you have specific treatment I
might be available there's also a lot of
different clinical trial that could be
used so based on on the information you
know this Matthew Kenny's was an
activating mutation there is the air
proof that are of label there is also
different clinical trial in earlier
phase though in this case and then
there's also information from a
treatment perspective that you can get
when you're looking at the p53
the variance as well with the we
inhibitor so in summary with to like to
see I interpret its allowing you to
essentially see all the variant you have
in the particular case and today we have
to take a look at at the breast cancer
case but you can certainly do that for
the software is really launched for the
oncology so we the inhibited cases or
somatic cases or solid tumor or liquid
biopsy if you're doing more blood type
of investigation the dashboard allows
you to the interface allows you to add
the risk contextual clinical case calls
access to bibliographic information to
make your decision access to treatment
and trial information also to help
supporting the decision of the variant
scientist and the clinical laboratory
and finally it also allow you to
generate your report add your overall
interpretive come in with the
information that is needed for the
particular case and then generate the
report so in essence you can see current
with the courage and knowledge base on
the weekly basis there's new information
the clinical bicycle type of finding
available status of drug clinical trial
that sort of thing it allows you to
increase your throughput that your
clinical geneticists and variant
analysis can do for interpretation and
reporting it allows you to secure us
with the industry-leading knowledge of
information up to date as I mentioned
it's also allow you to improve your our
clinical decision making by a
somatically applying relevant
professional guidelines very
anticipation rule to deliver actionable
and evidence-based information and then
it can be customized to get maximum
flexibility of integration within your
internal system your laboratory policy
there's possibility of of making this
and an out of your laboratory director
team or medical director team to to
actually drive the policy that are
applicable for for for for each of the
cases and then the works that are
applicable for your laboratory and then
finally you also develop a primer a
private lab specific knowledge base so
what we have not seen because I haven't
been able to really go in the interface
itself is that it's you can see whether
you have seen this particular variant in
the number of case every time in new
cases so I will conclude my presentation
here and thank you for being with us
today it was a miss pleasure for me to
do this presentation and now I believe
we will open for a question
excellent presentation dr. ditions
thanks for bringing that information to
us before we get started with all of
your questions here's a quick reminder
about how to reach us today questions
can be sent via the green Q&A button at
the lower left of the presentation
window we'll get to as many as we can
our first question is thank you for the
interesting case studies the triple
negative breast cancer case seems like a
great example of how precision medicine
will help in the clinic can you
elaborate more sure yeah thank thank you
dr. Gerson's for that that great
presentation this is dr. Dale hand we
relax them so this is a this is an
excellent question so so this is a
classical example fantastic example of
how precision oncology or targeted
therapy bill will will probably be the
only option on only available treatment
a treatment option for this patient as
you mentioned triple negative breast
cancer is pretty pretty challenging to
treat especially especially because the
patient cannot be treated with trust
assume app because the patient doesn't
ever hurt to mutation o NT ligands like
time of the feeling for the absence of
estrogen receptor and progesterone
receptor so typically in the clinic what
would happen is a triple negative breast
cancer patient would be treated with
with an Recycling's like doxorubicin
know if you
zing-o-o-o-o taxes like docetaxel or
paclitaxel but the problem with this
chemotherapy is that that there are a
lot of side effects there are a lot of
very dreadful toxicities especially
especially especially in the especially
in the case of dr. rockzo route between
many patients who have traveled like
cardiac complications so I'm pretty sure
when the Wendy's patients trick-trick
treating oncologists or the source or
the clinical reports he or she would
have been really really really happy
because most likely this patient would
have exhausted two or three lines of
treatment and at this point the patient
only recourse would be would have been
hospice but in this case there was a map
to k1 mutation and this is like a really
really great example I was very happy
when I when I did the analysis where the
patient could be treated with the
treated with imatinib off-label so of
off level in the city in the sense that
it's approved for malignant melanoma in
2014 so what the gossip and also there
was another meeting hip the Kobe
McKinney bridge was approved last year
so what would what the oncologist would
typically do is okay there is an
approved drug for this particular
mutation in a different different
indication so the oncologist can use the
clinic clinical information in our
application and write to the insurance
company a letter of medical necessity so
this should facilitate the the the the
doctor to obtain prior authorization
from the front from the insurance
provider because these targeted therapy
is not not not cheap from a teeny bit
about $15,000 a month so so when they
get the insurance prior authorization
the patient could be patient to be
treated with imatinib o or copy Melanie
or alternately the patient could have
increased could be treated in clinical
trial setting if if if a trial is
available close close to the
geographical locality of the of the
patient and oncologist so again this was
a great example of targeted therapy
helping the bruschetta
a patient thank you doctor we're at need
from a variant scientist slash clinical
geneticist point of view how would you
see I interpret help clinical lab so so
most of the time spent by various
scientists is on the literature curation
and variant interpretation so we have
done internal study here at Chiron and
we have shown that QC I interpret
reduces that this test interpretation
time buys almost seventy five percent
the time that is saved by this can be
used for secondary review QA and
compliance and especially for
scalability so under clinical decision
support products and update variants
using public databases like h d and d o
oakland ma from primary literature and
this becomes challenging especially if
the variant interpretation is tied to a
CMD classification and as a as dr.
technicians mentioned that the strong
point of the of this whole application
is the underlying knowledge base our
knowledge base is curated by PhD level
curators and we curate things from
primary literature clinical guide to
clicker guidelines not only in CCA like
many clinical many different clinical
type guidelines and fda and EMA drug
labels I think the other definitive
advantage of QC I interpret over other
clip other clinical decision support
systems is that they interpret assesses
the entire genetic profile in its
entirety so mething combination variants
of multi variant switch therapy so if
there is a if there's one single variate
if the the the therapy of the
recommendations that would be given
would would not be on a particular
variant but but the composite the
molecular profile of that patient which
is because how a patient should be
treated in the clinic what data sources
are integrated into this tool can you
list them
we'll be a little bit too long to
integrate there's about 30 different
sources so the way kangan is building
the knowledge base is we we first for
sure have you know what's the typical
data bases that you would think such as
kin var cosmic hgmd databases you also
have for example if we think about
guideline you have NCCN fda EMEA
guidelines you also have things such as
clinical trials at gore that is
integrated that we curate fully which
means that we will not just integrate
the databases but we will also make sure
that the status the criteria match as
dr. verrity has said and there's there's
primary literature so Karen also bulk
all the little diagram that I was
showing these are primary literature we
curate at cottage and directly so we
have our team of curator that will read
these clinical paper and they are their
primary clinical case in most of the
cases there's also databases when you
think about protein function with that
will be used there's also different
protein predictor type of databases if
fall offends that sort of thing that
will also be integrated there's a lot
about 30 or so of them and we will be
more than happy to have one for support
and scientists reality personally after
and and provide you to list and and
correct you know all the information
about the different databases for genes
that have multiple transcripts which
grant transcript do you represent on QC
I interpret and also do you have
information unless you're known
transcripts oh that's a great question a
question we get to get quite often from
our class yeah yes we do so for genes
that have multiple transcript the
courage and before craf it is the one we
have most number of findings in our in
our in our database typically dis
represent the most clinical clinically
relevant transcript
so if two class trips have the same
number of findings in our in our
knowledgebase we we would consider we
would assign the long the transcript
tester as the default transcript but
this does not mean to say that that the
transcripts are not available every
single transcript can be selected by our
top troubling troubling at that at that
particular section so for example we
have information for FGFR one like many
of you know has multiple transcripts so
we have nine different transcripts in in
our QC I interpret app application for
gene as another common gene there there
are there are multiple transcripts we
have seven different transcripts in our
in our application so if you are
interested in a particular transcript
you can easily scroll down and select
the transcript of interest well thank
you and for those if we didn't get your
question today we will follow up with
you via email I would like to once again
thank dr. Duchenne's for her
presentation and also dr. Weir at me do
you have any final comments for us today
um not really I hope everyone has a
great day and thank you for for being
with us today it's what is a pleasure
for us thank you very much thank you
both I would also like to thank our
sponsor cryogen bioinformatics for
making it possible to bring this
presentation to you this webinar has
been approved for continuing educational
credits please click on the CD button at
the bottom left corner and follow the
process to receive your credits
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through February 2017
you'll receive an email from us alerting
you when it's available on demand and
posted on lab routes calm you are
welcome to forward this announcement to
any colleagues who weren't able to join
in today thanks for logging on and
participating in today's broadcast see
you next time